in den letzten wochen haben putin und
seine propagandisten wiederholt auch
über den gebrauch von atomwaffen
fabuliert das ziel natürlich exakt auf
unsere ängste niemand weiß wie weit
putin wirklich gehen wird prinzip der
atomaren bewaffnung war aber eigentlich
ja immer dass niemand atomwaffen
einsetzt weil es auch den eigenen
untergang bedeuten würde das so genannte
gleichgewicht des schreckens und deshalb
haben auch die amerikaner ein
gigantisches
atomwaffenarsenal bild reporter herbert
bauernebel hat nun einen exklusiven
einblick in ein altes raketen silo
bekommen
nie war die angst vor einem atomkrieg so
groß wie jetzt nicht mehr seit dem fall
des eisernen vorhangs
damals am höhepunkt des kalten krieges
waren rund 1000 atomraketen an
entlegenen orten der zentralen und
nordwestlichen usa stationiert so auch
in der weiten prärie von montana im zuge
der atomaren abrüstung wurde deren
anzahl zwar deutlich verringert doch
noch immer warten in zahlreichen
unterirdischen silos joe biden
vergeltungs atomraketen auf putin so nah
kann man an einem raketen ziele heran
kommen in montana hier in der offenen
weide das sieht man diese abschussanlage
ein atom silo drinnen eine management
drei
nuklearraketen eine atomrakete am
neuesten stand amerikanische atomwaffen
und das sind sie rund 18 meter lang und
36 tonnen schwer in 3,4 sekunden steigt
die minutemen aus dem silo würde zuerst
ins alle rasen und dann mit 23 fachen
überschall auf ein vorher ein
programmiertes ziel zu stürzen beladen
mit einem nuklearen sprengkopf 20 mal so
verheerend wie big boi jene atomrakete
die 1945 hiroshima dem erdboden
gleichgemacht hat man erreicht das
kommandozentrum durch einen lift der
hier ungefähr vier bis fünf stockwerke
in die tiefe geht und erreicht eben
diesen unterirdischen raum das ist ein
kommandozentrum zentrum wir es noch
anfang der 90er jahre aus gesehen hat
diese unterirdischen kommandozentralen
mussten zu jeder zeit mit zwei
offizieren besetzt sein einziger kontakt
zur außenwelt die standleitung zum
militärischen hauptquartier in
washington dc um zu verstehen wie der
ablauf im ernstfall ausgesehen hätte
haben wir den ehemaligen kommandanten
der anlage jim wünsche an seinen
früheren arbeitsplatz begleitet er zeigt
uns exklusiv was im ernstfall passiert
wäre und wie es auch heute noch ablaufen
würde
als erstes hätten wir auf diesem gerät
hier eine nachricht erhalten die
nachricht wäre direkt aus dem
hauptquartier gekommen und sie sehe für
einen unbeteiligten aus wie
buchstabensalat aber wir hätten das dann
entziffern können um ein unteroffizier
wäre wahrscheinlich zu mir rüber
gelaufen hätte mir gesagt dass hier eine
nachricht an kommt dann hätten wir das
gegengecheckt überprüft ob der befehl
korrekt gewesen wäre ist der befehl zum
einleiten des raketenstarts erteilt
zählt jede sekunde
dann müssen wir die rakete scharf
stellen das kann man sich vorstellen wie
bei einer pistole erst and regeln dann
kann man den abzug drücken dann hätten
wir eine so genannte plc nummer
eingegeben das waren zahlen von 0 bis 99
die mit den vorgaben des präsidenten
korrespondiert haben gaben dann die
ziele vor auf die wie die raketen
gerichtet haben ungefähr fünf sekunden
später hätte ich dann zu meinem
unteroffizier gesagt auf mein kommando
und dann hätte ich runtergezählt sobald
das zweite start protokoll von einer
anderen kommandozentrale bestätigt
worden wäre wäre der so genannte
terminal countdown in gang gesetzt
wurden und dieser terminal countdown
heißt nicht umsonst so einmal
eingeleitet gibt es keine so rückt
unaufhaltsam heißt auch unaufhaltsam das
sind keine ferngesteuerten waffen das
war auch so beabsichtigt weil man
verhindern wollte dass der feind von
außen einfluss nehmen könnte er könnte
die rakete ja dann womöglich übernehmen
und das disneyland oder sowas zu steuern
absolut kein platz für irrtümer und
schon gar nicht für zweifel auch aus
diesem grund ist der besatzung im
kommandobunker das genaue ziel auf dass
die rakete gerichtet ist nicht bekannt
nehmen wir mal an sie hätten eine tante
matilda in der ukraine
die ukraine war eines von vier zielen in
der sowjetunion auf dass unsere waffen
gerichtet waren womöglich hätte man
gezögert wenn man gewusst hätte dass man
die rakete auf das haus seines tanzens
zusteuert
sowie den amerikanern war und ist der
gegenseite natürlich auch bekannt wo die
stationären atomraketen in den usa
positioniert sind in diesem
gleichgewicht des schreckens hätte in
zeiten des kalten krieges jeder staat
nuklear bewaffneter raketen einen
unmittelbaren gegenschlag zur folge
gehabt auch die männer in den
unterirdischen raketensilos wären
zweifelsfrei zum ziel solcher reaktionen
geworden
durch simulationen wurde festgestellt
dass ein einschlag gehen diese
kommandozentrale verheerende folgen
gehabt hätte das hätten wir nicht
überlebt jetzt da die russische
föderation die ukraine überfallen hat
und dem rest der welt zu verstehen
gegeben hat dass man nicht davor
zurückschreckt atomwaffen zu benutzen
rückt eine eskalation der nuklearen
bedrohung durch russland wieder in den
rahmen des möglichen
ich muss ehrlich gesagt zu geben die
situation heute bereits viel mehr sorgen
als das was damals los war damals hatten
wir das wesentlich besser
droht uns erneut atomares wettrüsten
100 megatonnen an atomare sprengkraft
könnten die menschheit auslöschen ein
bruchteil dessen was putins
atomwaffenarsenal und dem der usa zur
verfügung steht